mais que ça va pas tarder bon on a fait
ce que nous allons garder notre calme
on a montré qu'on était responsable cet
escadron de gendarmes mobiles partent à
l'assaut de l'église saint-bernard
protégé par plusieurs centaines de
sympathisants qui ont passé toute la
nuit à veiller ici le bouclier humain ne
tient pas longtemps à l'intérieur au
centre de la nef
alors que les familles se regroupent
dans le calme les barricades de fortune
se dresse devant les fleurs
sous les coups de hache elle fait les
policiers pénètrent la chasse commence à
l'encontre des résistants évacué sans
ménagement
un vacarme et une panique suivons à 0
and office offre refusée par le curé de
la paroisse je peux comprendre plus
arrêts
j'ai un peu honte chapeau aux formes aux
prises en charge par les pompiers et
médecins du monde
les dix grévistes de la faim sont à leur
tour évacuées vers deux hôpitaux
militaires entre les délégués des
familles et les policiers qu une
dernière tentative de négociation ne
seriez pas là aujourd'hui madame à la
loi ou la farbio le porte-parole des
sans papiers est alors expulsé stadion
am d'alors l'opération touche à sa fin
on regroupe et triés par catégories des
familles des célibataires
chacun se résigne à quitter les lieux
dans la dignité sans illusion sur la
destination fait pour le centre de
rétention de vincennes à quelques
centaines de mètres de l'église 2000
manifestants rendent une dernière fois
hommage aux sans papiers avant de se
rendre place de la république